[Music]
curry is a home robot that responds to
your voice and touch he can play music
navigate around your house and record
video but most importantly he wants to
be your friend I don't foresee myself
becoming like super close with curry I
can definitely get attached to a robot
why I'm not a very social person you
know all my best friends aren't three
cats all right I'm ready to meet curry
please bring it on it's just look I'm
shaking right now
hi I'm Jan I work with the team at
develop curry over in California and
he's an adorable home robot let's get
curry in here let's go play with courage
all right curry
welcome to BuzzFeed let's have some fun
we're here at my desk and we have
Vanessa Vanessa yeah come meet curry
he's coming so let's go take a walk
around with
my little new buddy he literally has
fans right now are they bothering you
all right guys what do you think about
curry okay
he's like the nicest person ever I don't
need any of these creatures here what a
waste what a waste of time
Hickory I know that you don't speak
English but tell me a joke oh [ __ ] that
was funny
he's like angel curry you want to go and
like try to find a wig I think you're
gonna it's gonna suit you that silence
is like don't even try [ __ ] what so
sorry he's allergic to me and for
curries last trick hey curry clay me
your favorite song
[Music]
pancake robot ever heard of the thing is
getting ready to leave it is this a sad
moment guys I'm just not sure I'm ready
for this but [ __ ] like you gotta get the
strength and do it if there's one thing
I learned is that he gets all the
attention yo that's my stuff it's like
walking around with a prettier friend
and you like this [ __ ] no button no one
looks at curry and I had a really really
nice day together but eventually he had
to go and it was pretty sad really I did
not expect it have so much fun with a
robot
I was super skeptical of curry and
hanging out with a robot all day it was
insane I feel like walking with a tiny
celebrity I think curry is so cute
he doesn't really do a whole lot of
stuff but I like it because I think if
he knew too much I'd be like super
freaked out I'm not bullshitting your
year I think by this time he and I are
best friends
hey curry I love you and I'm only
waiting for you to come back
[Music]